brockman and del tufo are in their usual
chairs and same thing with t.j jefferson
uh who
who did exactly what all cowboys fans
were doing on saturday night celebrating
a big time finale to the end of the
season going momentum filled into the
playoffs wondering where they would be
seated who would they be playing and
then also
uh sitting there um and talking about
how prior to the season they essentially
nailed mostly win-loss win loss of the
cowboys record it's factual my friend
and at the same time i was getting a
text from another cowboy friend and fan
of mine
uh a cowboy fan and friend of mine um
we're fans of each other
uh saying hey rich pull out that
schedule run you and i did on your show
i think i said they would be 12 and 5 or
11 and 6. he wants some credit
joining us here is that individual he's
a pro football hall of famer one of my
favorites uh my game day compadre
michael irvin
only you
only you
can describe the events so well written
thank you you better believe i called i
texted right away
let's pull back out that schedule
now the interesting thing is this was
done on june 24th and the reason why i
know the date is because it was my
birthday and you were kind enough to
call into my show and wish me a happy
birthday and i said for my birthday i
would like you to run through the
cowboys schedule and predict win losses
win losses and you didn't want to do it
like i kind of dragged you doing it and
then you did it
because i i said it's for my birthday
because you didn't want to put any
ziggies on your team we didn't know how
dak was going to be like he didn't want
to do it we had no idea
the difficulty of it not knowing where
that would be this could have been one
of those well you're going to miss the
first four games
you know but we we we went by what they
were saying that he's on time he's on
pace and everything's going to go well
and we'll assume they did and it did so
so we went to work with it okay so uh i
don't know how to handle this uh but you
said on that day michael
uh because the cowboys finished twelve
and five correct that's what they
finished they finished twelve and five
right that's what they finished okay
you said you you you
should should we just go through it yeah
let's just go through this okay
all right so you said that they would
lose to the bucks and they did
and then you said that they would win
every single game up to their buy and
they did
and they did and then you said they'd
come off the buy and they'd win it
minnesota which they did
and it was okay as a city in there
you you you then said that they'd beat
denver and they didn't but who the heck
saw that one coming you said they'd oh
that's true you did tj
okay all right you did have them as a
loss against us against denver so right
now you're tj you are one up on earth
yes on this one okay uh you both said
they beat atlanta you both said they'd
lose to kansas city
and they did
and then you you gave them wins on
thanksgiving they didn't get that
all
right to do that okay that's the deal
you said that well then you say they'd
lose to new orleans and they won
uh
you then irv said they'd lose to the
washington football team but at that
time we we were they were you know
coming off a terrific season and ryan
fitzpatrick was coming and i i was ready
to talk ryan would be there that ryan
fits magic or still one along with that
tradition of the cowboys and you know
washington tradition of rivalry yep uh
uh you did give him a win tj uh then you
said you'd they'd lose to the giants tj
michael correctly uh said they'd win
against the giants and then the
washington football team you both uh you
you said that michael they beat arizona
t.j you gave him a loss against arizona
you got that one i just you know some
things i saw rich so tj you had them go
11-6 you were off by one irv you then
said and i allowed this because i i
totally understood it that it was a
swinging gate in week 18 a win against
philadelphia if you needed it and to
start your starters or a loss if
philadelphia was going to start their
starters so i'm going to give you the
win there
and getting that correct you had them go
13 and 4.
[Music]
too most people predicted nine and eight
so that's true yeah
so we smashed it
yeah yeah man so i i lost that arizona
game you basically you said that was it
that was it won that game that one
should have won that game they would
have been 13 or 4. i know
i know
i know so um
let me ask you this question
if you could hand pick the team you
didn't want to see in the first round of
the playoffs would it have been the
49ers
michael
oh
absolutely as soon as when we got there
i said oh god
that's the latter not the 49ers man i
know 49
and you know i got friends here and they
were texting me uh that i go on there
with here and they were texting me man
it's great we got the 49ers though
russell that's the worst draw for us
the worst draw
the worst draw we want i wanted san fran
to go knock off green bay or the ram
before they came through here before we
saw them you know what i mean let me
tell you why the defense is an
opportunistic defense our opportunistic
defense
matt stafford if we had to see him he'll
give us something i believe tyler murray
if we had to see him again he would give
us something
cal shanahan
puts try to the best he can puts lock in
key on jimmy g
and he'll turn around and hand that ball
off the best he can to keep a lock and
key right on jimmy g you see what i mean
and it worries me and we saw what the
team what what philly did running the
ball against dallas even even half men
or half staff whatever half you want to
call they were ready at football and so
so yeah this was this is probably the
worst matchup that dallas offense
doesn't get a chance to kind of get
uh into playoff mode they have to start
quick to try to help this defense
eliminate that run game by dallas often
scoring points and debo too coming
downhill that's don't even mention debo
samuel who who i believe and i've seen
it uh earlier in this year
that they could easily put him in
contention for mvp if kyle shanahan
continued to overuse him you know this
dude has mvp like talent man what a
phenomenal year he did
i know and he's got the niners logo and
the number 19 on his thigh pads and he
just comes downhill and he hits you and
he doesn't care i love the way he plays
football and
so the tackle's too rich you know they
started running between the tackles i
mean i'm always on it
all those hoes are too tiny for me being
thinking about running up here but when
i see a receiver like that and and he
said that he is a receiver i can't call
him a running back to clan receiver
because most running backs can't track
balls like this dude track balls you
know what i'm saying down the field and
everything it's
really a phenomenal phenomenal talent
man it's been great to watch all right
so then let's give your your your team
some run then uh
what do the cowboys do to win this one
howdy what what gives you the the sense
that they can
match the physicality is the phrase i'm
sure we'll be using all weekend long
what do you got
right and here here's my issue richard
i'm i'm worried
that both sides
of the ball
on the line
the cowboys struggle here
the cowboys will struggle on both sides
that offensive line
the dallas offensive line going up
against
the san fran defensive line
george bush playing the way he plays
going that's going to that could be
tough
they got to be ready for this they got
to be prepared for this dallas defensive
line
going up against this run heaven
49ers offensive line when dallas really
have a bunch of dudes that want to get
to the quarterback they you know these
ain't this guy who just wanted to talk
tackle the runner all day they want to
get to the quarterback but but san fran
they come downhill running that football
so that that's going to be
tough
so dallas offense has to light it up
you can't come back you're not dallas is
not going to outrun the football better
than say a friend
but dallas can throw the ball
better than saying friend they have to
come out and light it up and it's so
crazy because all the we've been talking
about that prescott so much this has to
be a dark game
it's got to be a deck game oh man
i don't know
i mean he did
those honestly that
that was the b team for philadelphia and
i know we talked about it on sunday's
game day morning yeah you know that was
the b team you know uh the washington
game is the one that i would i'd hang my
hat on but then arizona's hat game
happened you know and chandler jones is
that physical type guy in the nfc west
that
that kind of blew things up a little bit
here right you know
what up for us and man i'm telling you i
i i i just that defensive line
for san fran is a problem
that's going to be
a problem and and that i know tyron all
of them are at their their best because
i you know what i would love to see rich
the young balance offensive line going
up against this
defensive line right you know when zach
and tyron and all of those guys were
young and going up against that young
[ __ ] what happened but we have
something you'll have something right
there but it'll be interesting to see
as is michael irvin what were your
what's your memories of your cowboys and
honors days
walk me through that
what do you got oh man there's so many i
know
so many like like like you know you
think about i think about when we were
getting ready to go down there and play
in 92 and at that first championship
game and everybody around here was
talking about the catch what happened
mad time to catch so catch the cats
again and then you know as as we're
going playing san francisco over there
alvin harper makes a long ticket down
the sideline that becomes our catch
you know that becomes our the catch
because all r i think about
the
[Music]
the game where
we're throwing
we're throwing this at 396 is the route
396. i got it out
uh jay has a down the middle alvin curls
right where his fight that jay lee's
running down the field on the nine rep
we had thrown that ball three times in
the game
and every time they saw it to alvin
harper
and now we're
we have we third is third down the game
is on the line
we tried this pastor alvin harper hadn't
completed it
when troy called to play he said step
right three nine well all i heard was
the three and the nine and i shout out
to alvin rock you i'm gone and everybody
looking and i said when to play i'm
running hard running to play and that's
where you know what are you doing that's
running the guards right right now
there's one to play cause i'm gonna get
this ball i'm about to be a hero i'm
about to save this day and we're gonna
win this game to go with the super bowl
so i snapped the ball they rotate the
coverage to me
on the curl route troy looks at me and
then turns back side and throws that
ball to avon harper alvin ross about 70
yards and i'm sitting there saying
looking hot with my football
and that's where troy walks by
and he's pointing that's what you get
you should have stuck to the plane and i
was just like oh no i'm trying to be the
hero and i made him the hero by taking
his spot and he took mine those things
you'll never forget because it's all in
game stuff when everybody's just trying
to win you know we're just trying to win
and and we were able to have a little
fun and the guys they mess with me about
that every time so aikman is like that's
what you get you know you don't get the
chance
that's what you get you should have
stuck to the play and he write it right
sloppy laughs
that is so funny
in the world man
oh my gosh
what are you doing that's a wonder damn
play like that i made a executive
defense in him run that play you know
and what about your battles what about
your battles with the eddie robinson
award winner for best coach uh for for
coach of the year uh and dion sanders
what about those days irv man seriously
and i'm so happy for dion right you know
oh my god you know we could do a
commercial tomorrow dion and i so you
know is that right yeah we have a
commercial to shoot uh
tomorrow tomorrow's wednesday you know
thursday friday
he wants to be called cody prime he's
what he says refer to him as cody prime
because cody stands for coach of the
year so call him cody primer
go to problem
i'm so happy when he got his when he got
his new hair he was come back player of
the year
now he's cody prime yeah that's what he
is i didn't hear that one to come back
yeah that's what he referred to himself
as comeback player of the year when he
got his new hair
he said he's a new dude man he's in the
duke you see times he's he's steady
snatching him now he's been snatching
him up he's been getting players
that other people sign but time comes in
it does this cell job and hey man those
those clips
you know they go with time i'm so happy
for him and and just the job he's done
he's recruiting man and i'm telling you
he loves what he's doing he loves where
he is
i come to the airport and i have no joke
i got guys you know guys that i see
coming through the airport man and they
always turn man tell dion thank you man
rich rich you guys
we look at the football
i got people a lot of people from
jackson mississippi management it's a
michael you don't know how much he's
affecting
the whole area it's one of the highest
crime rates and all that man he says
dion is affecting everything you know
and they just said man just tell him
thank you man just tell him thank you
for what he's doing
and how he's doing it so so i'm just so
happy for him so that's better than
let's we could talk about him and how
great he is and
all day but you know are you doing that
so you don't talk about him uh in that
championship game for the niners against
you
oh no no no
the game they won yeah is that what it
is i remember some past interference i
think i mean
we had a very heated segment on nfl
where the two of them got up and
recreated it i remember that it got a
little awkward didn't it got a little
awkward on live television every time
you see me say hey
i thought we worked through this i
thought you gotta let that go
[Music]
so he's always trying to tell me y'all
gotta let that go that's over man that
was not i said that's a pi time he said
there was no flag on the ground you know
he just loves to laugh about that but
what a great game what a great game that
was irv this is tj i'm looking at the
stats of that game and something just
jumped out me that at me that i never
knew uh the records that i broke in that
game
you had 12 for a buck 92 and two
touchdowns which is unbelievable which
was the nfc championship game record at
the time yes sir but you troy aikman
threw 53 passes that game you had 26
targets wow
i've never seen anything you had 26
targets
[Music]
actually the only time we've ever seen
26 targets in candlestick was when mooch
targeted teo that many times on jerry
rice day
[Laughter]
don't you ever mess with my story like
that tell him about all the third
targets all we were focused on was that
there was an nfc championship game
record you stay right there don't you
ever bury that league bringing the
targets up and diminishing the receiving
records don't you do that let's watch
one time just let that slide let that
target say slot don't mention that 12
for a buck 92 and two touchdowns
target you just snatched my glory away
you know that was that wasn't that
wasn't no no it's not his intent now
this is that coverage what it was
they would put time on me if they didn't
have time on me they double-teamed me
and they made time stop alvin harper or
somebody uh uh on the other side so i
didn't stop receiving on the other side
that's why
that's why on that curl ride i said i'm
running over here i'm gonna go running
this girl i catch a scroll route on the
uh i'll catch curl round on anybody
because curl route i'm just gonna body
you up and play defense i'm playing
basketball i'm gonna go down here 12 13
yards and i'm gonna put this big booty
on you
and it's gonna take something to come
around if you come around me it'll be
sure to pass the appearance it's going
to take something to come around me so i
can get that curl out the tight that's
what you put that's what how you do it
in the tight that's what michael calls
now the playoff time the type that's
what hey rich you gotta explain this to
people i tell i was telling them what
the playoffs are you watch players
because you see players in the regular
season wow and you'll see those same
players in the playoffs
and they don't play the same why is this
you do a study on why is this and it's
not that his skill set has diminished in
it it's how does he handle those
precious
situation more precious precious
situations pressure situations and those
precious pressure moments so so so
and we call them
i call it the tight because in the
playoffs everybody booty is so tight
everybody
that will determine if you are a winner
or if you're going home how do you
perform in the type that's what this
playoffs about
michael irvin
tight like that booty love you sir i'll
see you in a couple days take care all
right guys looking forward that's uh
michael irving game day morning by the
way uh at noon eastern on
saturday for four and a half hours and
then a 9 a.m eastern regular time on
sunday for four hours
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here